[Music]
was there a single event that led to you
being on the streets um pretty much so I
did 12 years service in the army I came
out with post-traumatic stress disorder
and then settled my own business and
through the total stress I was found
walking down a motorway the wrong way in
just a pair of slippers twelve weeks
later he said you can go now
and I came out of hospital and I
literally had nowhere to go so I ended
up on the streets you know what started
you off on I think I was in care for 16
years from the age of 2 when I turned 18
I was put into a hostel didn't have no
kind of life skills no support nothing
like been institutionalized most of my
life and I struggled in that environment
a lot of the people that lived in that
environment were quite unhealthy people
for me to be around did you get addicted
to certain substances yeah so from me
first picking up a class a substance I
was homeless on the streets pretty
quickly after that it was a matter of I
don't even think it was a month and I
remember sleeping in the back of a car
park and kind of looking I'm thinking my
you know this has happened really quick
from that point onwards that's kind of
how I ended up on the streets for four
years yeah I did nearly five years on
the streets my cell
describe the first night on the streets
I can remember it quite clearly so there
was me and my two friends and we slept
in soy sauce car park in Birmingham city
centre and I remember waking off about
two or three o'clock in the morning and
being absolutely freezing cold sleeping
on these concrete stairs and he taking
me so long to get back to sleep and I
remember getting woken up by a security
guard at 6 o'clock in the morning and
the guy was actually not kicking me in
my sleeping bag and when I woke up
someone had robbed trainers as well so I
woke up with no shoes and then
Babbington warfarin city centre in the
morning in my socks and just thinking
why that would that was why I was not a
nice experience has been through a very
similar I woke up one morning and
someone had pinched one boots I addict
Charles blanket to cover me there and
found in a bed that actually someone had
been sickle I didn't realize but I
dragged out the bend I put old me to
keep myself warm I think for me that was
the first proper point mo I actually
realized the things that up to that
point I took for granted so kind of
those home comforts and having a roof
over my head and being able to wake up
in the morning and kind of go and make a
cup of coffee or have a wash or brush my
teeth in that morning when I woke up
that guy kicking me in that car parked
on a real always been this is something
completely different
hi the next one where could you shower
whilst homeless I used to actually go
down to the canal um Rockdale come out
while I was in Manchester um I had
washed down actually from the canal and
the other problem is you know toilets
there's no public toilets available to
homeless people and keeping yourself
clean and tidy is something that um it's
very difficult when you're on the street
where you've ever attacked on the street
yeah I remember being kicked and
physically kicked in a sleeping bag when
I came to Manchester and hence did not
be teeth out I was scarred here and
there and I thought you know well after
all the time in the army you know I'd be
used to the streets but I wasn't out
it's it's all tweaked different life I
got stabbed eight times and then also
when people used to bat drinking I mean
woke up in the morning people had no
weed on Austin's
stuff like that at times I went down to
a bridge under the canal
away from sitting on the streets and all
you seen is a pair of legs walking past
it all the time I just get down there
and hide away yeah I can relate to that
you know I'd end up waking up and
they're just be hundreds of people
around and without even not anybody kind
of even paying the slightest bit of
attention so yeah so I get a thing about
sleeping somewhere at times that it's
away from all of that so that isn't
something you gotta deal with I can take
you kicking on the street everybody does
but it's the verbal side of it that hurt
you you know get a job get a job you
know I'm 64 years of age and I've worked
all my life for the last four years
okay I've been on the streets
you probably had this yourself people
kind of not seen past that the fact that
I'm actually still human being I'm still
a person you know I've got a story all
the clothes that I was homeless we've
rough sleeping for me become the norm
that was a routine to me that was what I
knew that was my safety blanket
you know I slept through four winters on
the streets where it was not bitterly
cold and I'm sleeping outside in a
sleeping bag
I'm a jovial sort of a drunk alcohol or
news drugs
so it was an escape from reality thought
he said it got me through those days
when I was at my lowest points when I
was like I couldn't wake in the morning
suicidal it made me feel further and
further away from kind of society when I
really wanted to transition back into
society because for so much my life had
about not part of it yeah that cycle is
that you you want help but you don't
know where to ask but
that's um you know it's it's very very
difficult to find not everybody has
events during their life that need them
to a point where they're become homeless
could come from somebody coming into the
country that can't client benefits it
may be somebody with underlying mental
health issues you know physical abuse
mental abuse just somebody getting and
losing their job and you know getting
into financial difficulty it could be
quite difficult for someone to
understand water its gas the streets you
know there's plenty of hospitals orders
there's plenty of houses around but but
just putting somebody in four walls for
my experience and when I was homeless it
was a process over a period of time
where I needed to start fixing these
little things and doing this process to
be able to tie my life around when I
first got my accommodation which um I
mean now I found it very difficult to
paying bills and different things
definitely how next one what impact has
been homeless had on your family Oh a
great deal my eldest sister that
reported me as a missing person she
still says that part of my life didn't
happen well sorry wolf it did happen why
didn't you tell us that you you were in
that state I'm like well how do you how
do you do that I drove that conversation
how do you do that I just didn't know
what the tire miles would do it I don't
even know if more family apart from
above a knew that I was even though I
miss for that time because since I've
had the conversation if I'm a dad and I
don't even think he knew about it I
think it's more shocking for their name
probably has a bigger impact
than he did back then okay should people
give change to the street homeless we
work a lot now with different
organizations and we get asked this
question all the time we say it's
personal choice so if you don't want to
give it to the person donate it to one
of them organizations I feel like maybe
there's the misconception that everybody
that's homeless is going to use that
money because they're drinking or
they're using drugs which actually isn't
the reality there are plenty of people
that rough sleep that actually do not
dream can do not type yes and would not
use that money to do that
so just walk past someone and you're
safe okay I've got nothing to give you
today but I hope you you get through it
um you know yourself that means a lot to
someone when you're on the streets just
to say Oh someone's realized I'm here
looking back I feel without the
opportunities that were placed into my
path by the different organizations that
were working with me at the time I don't
ever think that I would have got to this
point you know I've got partner I've got
home I've got my kids I've got all you
know money in my pocket you know I've
got bed to sleep in tannoy my family
I've got peace of mind met my mom after
30 odd years and buckin contacted him a
dad I've got my dream job so I'm a drug
and alcohol counselor and I work with
all the rough sleepers in Birmingham but
he very similar in the way that you know
okay I've got myself off the street I'm
a qualified mentor I've got nice little
one bedroom bungalow now I'm doing the
street tours at the moment and I've just
actually had my boot published with my
poetry in which the proceeds will be
going back to homeless charities the
opportunity to kind of get homelessness
now there and keep it at the forefront
of people's minds and and what the
issues are
how we can try and address them that for
me is a really important thing now
someone asked me what do you get out of
volunteering and said it's not what I
get out of it it's what I'm putting back
into it
[Music]
you